All right, guys, let's go ahead and get set up for the zoom close.
So what I do is 20 minutes, 15, 20 minutes before the actual close.
I come over to my computer, I get my tabs all dialed in in order and that way I'm ready
to go.
So I want everything to be clean so I can just go click, click, click, click, click,
show them everything.
And it's just this nice, easy process.
So what I'm going to have you guys do hop over with me to my screen.
All right, guys, so what I'm looking at here and this we're going to reference this more
in the next lesson.
But I do want to mention that in the FFM closing script 2.0, I have put the that says zoom
close prep.
I like to put my tabs in order.
I'm actually going to move this so that it's right here at the top.
And this is the tabs that I like to pull up.
So I like to have something for my monopoly strategy.
So what I'll do is I'll just have like a window open that says, you know, if I'm doing because
in this example, I'm using Queen Creek concrete.
So I would like to use either some some other project in Queen Creek, which I could, but
I think it's more effective to use somebody in concrete.
So I'm going to use the Bentonville concrete example.
So I've just typed in in Google concrete Bentonville.
OK, now you can be strategic here if you're not ranked for every keyword, you may want
to go ahead and search for the keyword that you are ranked the best for so you don't look
like an idiot when you do that.
And I've done that before.
I'm like, hey, let me go ahead and search this.
I search it and I'm like, oh, where's my website?
So just, you know, this one, I know for this, I rank for almost anything.
So I'm not as worried.
But if you're only ranked for like five out of 10 terms, make sure to use the ones that
you're ranked for.
OK, so I have this.
That's one of the windows I like to have pulled up one of the tabs case studies.
So you can either use like, and this says case studies slash social proof, so you can
either have, you know, like we talked about in the screencast, you have text message screenshots
or emails or whatever that say, hey, you know, we've closed this huge deal, whatever.
Or case studies could be your actual website.
So what I'll probably do is I'll have this website actually pulled up.
So I'll have another tab with this website pulled up.
And then the other thing that I do as far as like case studies is I like to show with
the projects that are really producing leads, I like to show the leads.
Now, I don't recommend that you show the leads if you're not getting leads or if you're pre-selling,
right?
Or if this is your first project, sorry, not if you're pre-selling, but if this is your
first project and you don't have another project to say, hey, look how many leads this is getting.
Don't show them.
OK, only show what you have.
Does that make sense?
Now, I don't want you guys, this is what you got to be careful of.
I can make this look however I want.
I could get these guys, whoever this is, to believe that I can produce a lot of leads
based on what I'm seeing, what I'm showing here.
I could also get them to believe that I can rank anything based on my rankings.
But what you got to be careful of is you can paint this picture however you want.
But remember, if you oversell, you will deal with it later.
OK, so I'm going to show the leads just to show them the ability, but I'm still going
to pitch them on the 12 to 15 lead range.
I'm not going to have them expecting this.
I'm just going to show them the ability that I have to potentially get them this many.
So they know I'm not messing with it.
But some of you guys are going to watch this and go, well, I don't have any leads.
I don't have any sites producing leads.
It's OK.
Just don't show the leads.
Just don't overthink this part.
Last thing I like to pull up is the lead value calculator.
And if you are doing this for your first time, you may want to drop the numbers already in.
So 5,000, I like to zero this out, 5,000 being the average ticket price for concrete profit
margin.
I'm going to put it at 20 percent close rate.
I'm going to put it at 30.
And then I don't like to show what would you charge per lead because I ain't going to charge
per lead.
OK, so you can zoom in like you could tell.
Even at 100 percent, this is perfect.
It shows just this on my computer, but I like to even zoom in sometimes.
I don't even want them to think there's an option because I've already told them there's
not.
So these are the tabs that I have pulled up.
I get everything ready.
I make sure my audio is working.
I make sure my zoom is ready to go and definitely make sure that you record these calls, make
sure your Wi-Fi is good, get prepped.
And then what I do is for a few minutes right before the call, I get in the zone.
And I know that sounds kind of cheesy, kind of corny, but I literally think about this
and I go, OK, I got a lot of shit on my plate right now.
I got a lot going on.
I'm thinking about a lot of stuff.
I got a family, I got kids.
I got this thing.
I got this problem over here.
I got like, for example, right now, like I literally today, I have tax stuff I got to
deal with.
I'm looking at buying a property.
I got to go golf at, not got to, I get to go golf at five.
I got to jump on the phone with somebody for another real estate thing at two.
I got to zoom out like all this stuff.
What I do for the five minutes before the call is I sit and I go, all right, this is
everything that I am doing up to this point.
The leads I'm sending, the list I'm building, the reason you're in this damn program leads
to this moment right here.
And I don't want you to overthink it.
I don't want you to spook yourself out, but I want you to get pretty damn serious about
the fact that this is what matters.
And you performing for the next one hour and doing this correctly and being all in and
not distracted, phone on silent, kids quiet, internet working, this is where I make money.
I do a lot of shit that doesn't make money because I'm not perfect.
But this activity right here is the thing that moves the needle.
The more of this I do, which again, I'm talking to myself right now, like if I'm sitting there
five minutes for I'm like, this is the thing I got to be a 10.
This is the thing that I have to be present for.
This is the thing that I need to do correctly to provide for my family, to hit my goals,
to move that needle.
So get dialed in, turn your damn phone off, quit getting distracted and get locked in
about five minutes before mentally and get ready to go.